j'ai rencontré l'amour à 17 ans je suis
tombée amoureuse d'un mec super beau
enfin il était là celui que j'attendais
depuis si longtemps
celui qui allait mais mais mais paul et
me rassurer bref me rendre heureuse 1 au
début était merveilleux je me sentais
fort tu es libre j'étais amoureuse quoi
j'étais prête à tout pour que cette
histoire fonctionne
j'étais adolescente et je me sentais
seul et isolé
alors quand il est arrivé dans ma vie je
me suis sentie relié à quelqu'un lui
allait pouvoir me comprendre et me
protéger je me suis livré corps et âme à
cet homme j'avais confiance en lui il
avait sept ans de plus que moi et je les
laissais ma prendre l'avis m'apprendra à
être aimable
je voulais être une femme digne d'être
traîné et il voulait une femme
impeccable j'avais 18 ans lorsque j'ai
appris que j'étais enceinte
oui c'est un peu tôt pour avoir un bébé
mais je l'aimais et c'est à ce moment là
que mes problèmes ont commencé
durant mes premiers mois de grossesse
lily s'est mis à exercer sur moi la
violence physique il a commencé par une
claque puis au fur et à mesure des
disputes les les coûts étaient de plus
en plus fréquent de plus en plus
nombreux de plus en plus fort
je me suis sentie prise au piège
j'attendais une petite fille avec lui je
voulais pas défaire mes rêves de
princesses et de princes charmants
alors si je faisais des efforts notre
relation ça arrangerait sûrement il
redeviendra est gentil avec moi comme au
début
alors je faisais des efforts encore
encore et encore et pour éviter les
conflits je n'avais d'autre choix que de
me soumettre à son autorité et tous les
prétextes étaient bons pour me battre
même une blague pouvait l'énerver il m'a
même un jour cassé la mâchoire
alors je lui pardonnais petit à petit
mais je me méfiais de plus en plus de
lui le dernier mois de grossesse ça a
été un vrai cauchemar il
il exerça violence à ce moment là en
toute impunité
ces coûts sont de plus en plus menaçant
alors je pars me réfugier chez mes
parents puis je reviens parce qu'il
s'excuse puis je repars et reviens parce
qu il me promet de se faire soigner
puis je repars et reviens parce que il
menace de tuer tout le monde
c'est à travers une émission de télé que
j'ai mis des mots sur ce que je vivais
moi qui pensais vivre une situation si
particulière je faisais en fait partie
de ces centaines de milliers de femmes
que l'on nomme femme battue et qui
concerne une femme sur dix en france
je ne veux pas rester dans cette
situation
à présent tout me fait peur chez lui je
veux vraiment partir je sais pas comment
faire alors je continue mes allers
retours je pars quand la violence
arrivent et revient quand je le sens
calme et je temporise le temps de
trouver le bon moment pour partir
définitivement toute sécurité le bon
moment s'est présenté peu après mon
accouchement je sentais que je me serais
plus utile
j'avais mis notre bébé au monde et il
pouvait donc se débarrasser de moi
j'avais peur pour ma vie
et l'idée que sa violence puisse un jour
être répercutée sur la petite m'était
insupportable mais limite était atteinte
je suis parti
j'étais super fier de ma décision
j'allais pouvoir enfin revivre
normalement en toute liberté la liberté
de dire et de faire sans avoir peur je
suis parti mais la violence ne s'est pas
arrêté là
lui n'avait pas décidé de me laisser
tranquille
il n'a pas accepté du tout notre
séparation et s'en est suivie de longues
années d'harcèlement deux années de
coups de téléphone quotidien répétitif
et menaçant des visites inopinées chez
moi travail de mes parents au lycée à
mon lycée ne crever maisons dévastées
enlèvement de la petite
la liste est longue durant cette période
il installe un climat de peur et
d'angoissé
il s'arrange pour que l'on pense à lui
il déclenche des événements plus
surprenant est plus violents les uns que
les autres
j'étais sidéré face à son comportement
je passais ma vie chez les gendarmes
chez mon avocat au tribunal
5 s'amplifier de jour en jour il
devenait incontrôlable des visites
encadrées était organisée pour la petite
île avait défense de s'approcher de
notre domicile les gendarmes faisait des
rondes régulières devant notre maison
est pourtant un jour il a mis ses
menaces à exécution il est arrivé en
pleine nuit armé d'un fusil
mes parents ma fille et moi étions
présents la vie de ma fille n'a pas été
mis en danger mais mes parents et moi
avons été laissé pour mort
ma maman et moi en sommes revenus mais
mon père est décédé
elle lui
il est incarcéré avec une peine de 20
ans de sûreté alors je me demande
comment on en est arrivé là
j'avais pourtant tout bien fait comme on
m'avait dit j'avais usé de tous les
recours qui m'était possible
j'avais foi en la justice alors au fur
et à mesure ou de déclencher des
événements jeu je déposerai des plaintes
qui engendrait souvent des peines de
prison avec sursis
des mesures étaient prises pour que nous
ayons le moins de contacts possibles
mais nous étions reliés par la petite et
j'avais des obligations face à lui ce
lien maintenu lui ouvrait des portes
pour me détruire
les condamnations se succéder mais rien
de changé au contraire signs
s'amplifiait sa colère grandissait et
les moyens qu'il usait pour me détruire
grandissez avec je m'arme est patience
pour ne pas répondre à ces agressions à
ces menaces
pour ne pas céder à la panique je criais
haut et fort les problèmes que j'avais
avec cet os mais l'écrin que j'avais et
lui aussi il criait au secours à sa
manière il tire l alarme
il savait de quoi il était capable et il
le disait il a même deux mois avant le
drame
appeler le commissariat pour dire qu'il
y allait avoir un meurtre à l'adresse de
mes parents alors je comprends que les
prisons soient surchargées et qu'on ne
puisse pas enfermer tout
toutes les personnes menaçante mais on
ne peut pas non plus laisser la
situation pourrir jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait
des morts
et même s'il avait pris quelques mois de
prison je suis pas convaincu que ça
aurait suffi à désamorcer sa colère on
va le faire relativiser je pensais aux
représailles à la sortie il n'y avait
pas de réelle solution pour me protéger
j'ai rencontré des professionnels
démunis n'avais ni les moyens d'agir
ni les outils adaptés à ce type de
problème et lui allaient jamais assez
loin pour être psychiatriquement
admissibles ou être pénalement
condamnable et plus il passé entre les
mailles de la justice plus ils se
sentaient forts et indestructible il
était dans les pleins pouvoirs pour que
la situation cesse il n'y avait qu'à
attendre qu'il commette l'irréparable
et ce n'est pas un fait si exceptionnel
puisque en 2013 tous les 2,5 jours c'est
à dire le jour et demi une personne est
morte dans un contexte de violence
conjugale est encore là ne sont pas
comptées les les morts collatéraux comme
mon papa
par exemple et je ne peux m'empêcher de
me demander quand je vois ces chiffres
combien y at il eu d'appel au secours
si vous ou l'un de vos proches étaient
dans cette situation
n'aimeriez vous pas qu'il existe les
moyens de vous protéger
ne peut-on rien faire contre cette
violence et avec l'avancée de la
psychanalyse et des neurosciences ne
peut-on pas détecté la détermination de
ces hommes et les prendre en charge plus
tôt pour qu'ils évitent de devenir des
assassins
à sa condamnation je me dis que j'ai 20
ans devant moi je dois les utiliser pour
me reconstruire mais aussi pour
comprendre alors je travaille avec
l'aide de thérapeutes
je me nourris de lecture et de
témoignages je m'inspire du vécu des
autres pour trouver des réponses à ma
propre existence et je rencontre
d'autres femmes qui ont subi des
violences physiques ou psychologiques et
je me rends compte que on a tout les
mêmes mots pour décrire ce que l'on a
vécu qu'on a toutes rencontré les mêmes
obstacles qui nous ont empêchés nous en
sortir et que c'est ça qui nous a
détruites ne pas pouvoir nous en sortir
de la rencontre avec ces femmes mme
nelles envie d'agir
je me dis que si on laisse de autant de
personnes dans dans une telle détresse
c'est parce qu'on ne sait pas c'est
parce qu'on ne connaît pas bien les
violences conjugales moi même avant de
vivre ça je j'avais les idées reçues je
ne savais pas que qu'une personne
pouvait avoir autant de pouvoirs dans
une vie et qu'il était pas si facile de
s'en défaire je ne savais pas qu'une
merveilleuse histoire d'amour à 17 ans
pouvait devenir mortel alors je me dis
qu'il est il urgent d'informer
d'interpeller les consciences jeu je
veux qu'on comprenne qu avant tout ce
sont des histoires d'amour je veux qu'on
comprenne que ce ne sont pas des pauvres
femmes qui aiment ça
nous sommes pris au piège par des
représentations nous mêmes par des
représentations de la vie par l'emprise
de l'autre et il ne suffit pas de partir
pour que la violence cesse et il me
semble qu'il est urgent d'obtenir le
droit de quitter quelqu'un sans en
mourir
le droit de vivre après les violences
conjugales les droits de vivre en paix
je me questionne sur le meilleur moyen
d'agir à la place où je me trouve je
suis comédienne emma meilleures armes à
moi c'est le théâtre alors avec la
compagnie avec lequel je travaille
nous créons en janvier 2013 je te veux
impeccable pendant plusieurs années j'ai
suivi des violences conjugales
je les ai supporté entre mes 17 et mes
20 ans aujourd'hui j'ai besoin de vous
livrer mon histoire je te veux
impeccable et il me pièce écrite par
théo balles témoignent âge d'une
histoire vraie de femmes ayant subi des
violences conjugales sept mois sans
guide
j'ai raconté cette histoire de femmes
battues pour aider d'autres femmes des
témoignages peuvent aider à réaliser au
ou à ouvrir les yeux sur leur situation
même chose cette pièce montre que le
théâtre est un outil au service d'une
cause mais en même temps par son
exigence esthétique donne à cet outil là
ta force c'est un mes rôles aussi dont
interpeller les consciences
je parle d'un problème que je connais et
c'est une pièce qui a un rôle militant
et social
par ailleurs
cette pièce on se laisse traverser et on
fait beaucoup de places sans pour faire
entrer le personnage est entré toutes
les émotions qui vont avec ça passe plus
par le par le raisonnement mais par le
choeur et par l'émotionnel
la pièce s'adresse à tous les publics en
fait cette pièce elle raconte une
histoire d'amour qui finit mal et c'est
des sentiments universels
je me vois
cette pièce est sortie en 2013 et a été
édité en 2014
elle est devenue un outil d'information
auprès des lycéens par exemple mais
aussi de discussion puisque après chaque
représentation je propose un débat une
discussion avec le public qui est
composé de personnes lambda mais aussi
de beaucoup de professionnels par la
libération de la parole j'espère
qu'ensemble nous pourrons trouver des
solutions de plus en plus humaine pour
venir à bout de ce fléau
ce spectacle répond également à un mon
besoin d'agir à ne pas rester les bras
croisés à prendre mon destin en main
elle a aussi le bénéfice de rendre moins
absurde la mort de mon père
notre histoire mis en mots et en scène
devient utile elle prend un sens et
c'est ce qui concrètement nous libère
seize ans passés et il me reste du
chemin à parcourir
je n'ai d'autre choix que d'accepter le
scénario de ma vie et composer avec
j'essaie de rester ouvertes de ne pas
céder au découragement de faire toujours
le pas de plus j'ai pour objectif de
vivre sereinement
j'ai conscience aujourd'hui que moi
aussi j'ai le droit au bonheur
alors je dois bousculer ou éradiquer
tout ce qui fait obstacle à cela dans ma
vie ce qui m'empêche d'être pleinement
qui je suis c'est la violence je me suis
évidemment débarrasser de de toutes ces
violences extrêmes mais je me suis rendu
compte que ces violences pouvaient être
beaucoup plus subtil et qu'elle avait
une grande place dans le quotidien et
elle était tout aussi destructrice alors
je vais d banalise tout ces violences
qui qui sont présentes partout de des
cours d'école aux entreprises je l'aide
et normalise pour ne plus en recevoir
mais aussi pour ne plus être tentés de
les rendre donc de les transmettre
ces violences me font perdre confiance
en moi alors je dois me connaître
suffisamment me reconstruire me
connaître et repousser les limites de
ces violences
pour ne plus en être victime ce qui est
formidable c'est que plus je mets des
limites à ces violences plus je
m'épanouis et plus je m'épanouis plus je
me sens sereine c'était programme madras
ouais excusez moi c'était preuve m'a
donné l'occasion de puiser en moi une
force que je ne soupçonnais pas mais il
me reste une chose à entretenir pour que
ma vie continue à avancer dans le bon
sens et mon moral
je suis naturellement attirés par ce qui
me fait broyer du noir
alors je m'astreins à m'entourer de
positif je fuis la mélancolie j'ai
acquis en 16 ans des outils comme la
méditation ou la relaxation qui m'aident
à à traverser les périodes difficiles et
en cas de crise ce qui me fait changer
immédiatement d'humeur c'est de me
rallier avec ce que j'aimais quand
j'étais petit et ce qui me faisait
plaisir c'était de danser et vous avez
remarqué comme comme parfois certaines
chansons paraissent avoir été écrit pour
nous et c'est cela que j'ai envie de
partager avec vous ce soir et j'aurais
envie que vous m'accompagner dans la
douce folie
alors je vais vous demander de vous
lever je vais demander aux tedx de me
rejoindre et je vais demander à la lune
à alam
régis de mettre la musique et merci de
taper dans les mains dedans c'est
célébrer la vie avec moi
allez
ap
l'attenté je vais
basée tout recommencer
l'habitude